Assalamu alaykum Dr. Zakai. Walaykum.
Assalam. I am Savara from Usbakistan.
I am 18 years old. I'm a Muslim. I
prayed five times in a day in the past
and I did dua that I want to be the most
lovely servant of Allah. But I did one
sin. Many times I asked for his
forgiveness too many times. I felt that
he forgave me every time. I promised
Allah that I won't do this sin again.
But after a month, I did it again and I
again asked for his forgiveness. But I
think Allah didn't forgive me this time.
I cannot avoid the sin. I don't know why
but I really want to be close to Allah
to be his lovely servant. How often can
a person avoid a sin and what should I
do that Allah forgives me? The question
poses that a person did sin. He asked
for forgiveness and Allah forgive the
person and he he could know that Allah
forgive him. Then he promised Allah he
won't do it again and then again he did
the sin. What is the solution? As far as
forgiveness is concerned there are five
criterias required for forgiveness for
forgiveness for repentance there are
five criteria. Number one you should
agree that sin is wrong. Agree it is
wrong. Number two, stop it immediately.
Number three, commit to Allah subhanana
wa tala you will not do it again. Number
four is that you repent to Allah. And
number five, if you can undo it, undo
it. For example, if you have robbed
something, you can give it back, give it
back. Certain things you can't undo, no
problem. Then you have to do only the
first four things. Number one, agree it
is wrong. Number two, stop it. Number
three, don't do it again. Number four,
repent to Allah subhanaa tala. Ask for
forgiveness and inshallah, he'll forgive
you. Whatever the sin is, Allah says in
the Quran very clearly that however much
you sin and you ask forgiveness, Allah
will forgive you. There are various say
had of the prophet wasallam that the
prophet said that you commit sin the
full night and in the morning you ask
for forgiveness, Allah forgives you. You
commit sin the full day, in the night
you ask forgiveness from Allah and Allah
forgives you. So for repentance, agree
it is wrong, stop it, commit to Allah,
you won't do it again. They repent to
Allah and undo if you can. Now if you
commit a sin, you ask for forgiveness,
Allah forgives you again. You commit
this is what to do? I feel you should
feel remorseful. You should feel it is
something wrong. You should not take
your sin lightly. Don't take your sin
lightly. You ask Allah for Allah will
help you. If you sin 10 times, ask
forgiveness 10 times. Allah will forgive
you 10 times. You sin 100 times, ask
forgiveness 100 time, Allah will forgive
you 100 times. You sin thousand times,
Allah will forgive thousand. There is no
limit. But you can't plan. Okay, I'll
sin and I know I'm going to ask for
forgiven. Allah will forgive you. This
is planning. This Allah knows it will
not help you. But sincerely, if you do
something and you addicted to something
and you cannot come off it, sincerely
ask for forgiveness, sincerely tell
Allah you won't do it again. Maybe as
you said you did after one at least one
month you didn't sin then after one
month you sin again repent do all the
criterias really feel bad maybe then two
months you'll not do it then after 2
months you have sinned again ask Allah
for forgiveness again repent then maybe
you'll not do it for one year then maybe
after that you stop it completely you
never know so don't take it lightly keep
on asking for forgiveness Allah will
forgive you even if you do the biggest
sin of shik you ask for forgiveness
Allah Allah will forgive you. So asking
for forgiveness is very important and
you commit to Allah you won't do it
again. Inshallah Allah will help you. If
you happen to do it again again ask for
forgiveness. Allah will even forgive you
a million times. But see to it that you
repent sincerely for your forgiveness to
be accepted. So you said that last time
you felt Allah didn't accept your
forgiveness because maybe you didn't
repent sincerely. If you repent
sincerely, inshallah I'll forgive you.
However many times you do it and you
pray to Allah that you will not do it
again and you pray to Allah to guide
you, inshallah I'll guide you and you
pray to and I also pray to Allah subhana
wa t'ala that may this sin that you're
addicted to may be completely gone away
from your life and may Allah forgive all
your sin and may you be on the straight
path and may you enter Jenna inshallah.
Hope that answer the question.